if I had eBay and Etsy as a junior
high-end high school kid I don't know if
I would have graduated high school let
alone thought about going to college
these you know these kids know they can
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
in Creator revenue on these seven social
media platforms and why would they go
work for a shitty job with a bad culture
for 54 000 when they can do their art
whatever that may be for a hundred
thousand stay inner Nation how are you
I'm really excited about this uh I'm
just trying to mix up the guests talk
about different things obviously this
summer I've been very head down in the
execution of the V friends nft project
which has made me a little less loud
about my collecting and my admiration
and other things going on in the
ecosystem but today we changed that a
little bit up
um with a guest that I think will bring
a ton of value and inspiration and I'm
actually genuinely curious because we
haven't had a chance to chop up on how
her project is going and what she's
seeing and so that it's a real honor to
have you here you know I really admire
you from afar we haven't had the luxury
of that many interactions just yet but
I've been really looking forward to this
and I'm really happy for your success
and your community and I'm really glad
you're on the show
thanks thank you for having me thanks
yeah we haven't chatted uh I don't think
um directly but I've engaged with what
you've done and bacon was an absolute
success so yeah yeah it's a little dming
here and there but nothing too much so
let's get into this everybody gets to
see us do it here why don't you for the
uh Vayner nation and not only the V
friends Nation maybe give a little
backdrop why don't you take the first
two minutes and tell everybody who you
are and what you're up to professionally
sure so I am Betty founder of dead
fellas um dead fellas is a brand
um that was born from nfts we launched
our first nft collection
um Friday the 13th of August 2021 and
it's been an absolutely crazy ride ever
since
um we focus on digital identity and
extending into media and entertainment
we are storytellers but primarily I see
nfts and the technology behind it as a
proponent of social change and
disrupting uh you know everything from
industry to how people value creators so
it's a really exciting space to work in
take us all the way back a little bit to
little Betty like um where'd you grow up
what kind of kid were you were you
creative by Nature give us a little like
comic book number one origin story for a
few minutes little Betty okay
no one ever asks me this so that's cool
um I was born in Yorkshire which is in
the north of England yep
um my dad is and was
um a musician uh a thrash metal musician
um my mom is also a creative
um but also a um a nurse and so I was
raised in a in a household that
um while we you know we lived like in
like normal society and everything but I
was really pushed
um not pushed but like
celebrated for Creative Endeavors wow
yeah two parents that had so much
Creative Juice that the concept of
creativity was put on a pedestal the way
that sports or academics or financial
entrepreneurship might be in a different
household not just that but just just a
natural extension of how you go through
life like it was always present you know
so but also working outside of um
typically expected systems was something
that was celebrated like my mum was
raised as a you know devout Catholic but
then kind of went against her as an
adult and I got to be witness to that
and and as well say my by by dating a
thrash metal Superstar yeah yeah yeah
so I was the kid with the cool parents
um for sure it was it was it was good
um I've always been creative I've always
been I think I've I had an experience as
a kid where I I'd always be called bossy
and um I know that's different for men
they you know celebrated for leadership
whereas it's not the same experience for
women and girls but yeah I've always
been creative I've always found myself
can we can can we tap into that because
it's really funny you say that because
I'm 47 and one of the great things you
know I always my mom was such my hero
and continues to be
yeah and I always viewed her as very
strong you know and there was a lot of
strong women in my Eastern European
family and I you know I always
kind of took note of that in the 80s and
90s where where to your point if you
know if a woman entrepreneurially or in
a school play or whatever the setting
was
bossy was thrown around a lot and I
remember in my brain thinking that that
was like a good thing though I could see
that it was being used as not as much of
a good thing and you know
Society has a long ways to go on a many
magnitude of different issues but it
definitely has evolved uh you know into
a place where it's not as prevalent and
universally accepted that that was a bad
thing of being you know like and I see
far more you know girl dads and and boss
ladies a lot it's there's been a shift
but you're saying that for you it was
always like a part of like I'm a leader
right
yeah I've always felt that and I've
always gravitated to that and I've
always LED with that so
um it's always been a part of my
experience no matter what I do and I've
done many different things I speak about
that a lot to people
um the idea especially with Gen Z right
now where they're
um you know they're seen as lazy or they
don't want to work I I feel like I've
always kind of gone through life like
how they go through life now where they
just lead with like what they want to do
and they identify what works for them
and what doesn't work for them
um I think that gen Z are just you know
disenfranchised with the fact that the
systems in place are not they're never
going to work for the people they also
know Betty that they have options
exactly like like yeah like I identified
that too right like you could like you
would you know with you know for me for
example
if I had eBay and Etsy as a junior high
and high school kid I don't know if I
would have graduated high school let
alone thought about going to college
these you know these kids know they can
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
in Creator revenue on these seven social
media platforms and why would they go
work for a shitty job with a bad culture
for 54 000 when they can do their art
whatever that may be for a hundred
thousand yeah I think the definition of
success is also completely different now
um you know we were taught to follow a
path where you've got these Milestones
you have to reach by a certain age and
you know you have to get married have a
house have two kids all of this like fly
up the corporate ladder but like there
is no lighter for most people and for
most people like home ownership isn't a
realistic goal when working within those
systems so yeah I think totally agree my
being encouraged to uh to not subscribe
to that as a kid has set me up well
because I still don't and I applaud
anyone that doesn't now because I think
it's all rubbish needs to be burned to
the ground and started
I couldn't agree more I I'm such a fan
of that I I was ridiculed for lack of a
better word on my points of view about
college and it's Roi 15 years ago and
it's been fascinating to watch people
come around to at least the conversation
that one size doesn't fit all across
many things
speaking of which
um what do you think was one of the most
essential this is so many parents
listening right now have Creative Kids
and so many kids who are 14 12 9 17 are
listening right now do you have a
signature moment in your creative path
before let's say 21 that stands out as
like I got this affirmation or I got
this feeling in my tummy like was there
something is yeah please tell me I do uh
I was 19 years old always yeah I was 19
years old and my best friend died of
cancer and it was
something that I think many of us will
share as an experience whether you have
already or you will in the future
um but to me I was
in fact yeah I was so I was at
University I was studying biomed I was
good at it like good really good doing
really well
um but him dying kind of threw me into
like thinking about life and what like
do I want to work in a lab am I meant to
be in a lab am I meant to do this do I
really truly enjoy it or am I just
describing to something that I feel like
I should do because I am someone that
hits myself against myself and I want to
achieve and I want to you know
hit goals that I I set myself so it was
it was this internal Battle of like do I
continue have I wasted all this time
doing this
um and then it really introduced me to
the idea of the wasted time fallacy
which has also in my life completely
where
um you know there's this idea where if
you've invested a certain amount of time
into something you must finish
everything I love that
um but it's really not the case correct
you know I I identified that I had
learned so much from my time
um studying that and that it wasn't a
waste it's just set Beyond a different
path and I've I've kind of lived by that
rule ever since where I just go through
my life and I experience things and I
take what I need to take and I learn
what I need to learn I apply it to the
next thing and it's brought me where I
am today and you know some days I'll be
working and I'll be like oh
that kind of brings me back to like five
years ago or seven years ago where I had
this experience and so I do talk about
that a lot because I feel like it
encourages people that maybe feel like
they've wasted too much time they're in
their 30s like
I have three kids I'm 32. like
I've written so many different jobs and
done so many different things and you
know life is not linear and neither is
the professional path that you're on so
cheers for that I love you for that tell
me tell me
the couple of things that led to Deb
fellas from your perspective like the
things you were into as a kid or
something that made you realize what was
brewing in nft land if I asked you the
three or four ingredients before before
that faithful you know Friday the 13th
what do you think were the watershed
moments that led you to I'm gonna create
this in that ft form
um the first was being introduced to
nfts in general I saw it and was
immediately it was like a light bulb
moment like I know a lot of people need
convincing and need to learn more and
for me it was like holy [ __ ] this is
like so disruptive this is what I've
been waiting for I have been working a
lot with
um I mean I ran a creative production
agency prior to dead fellas with um
psych who is my co-founder and husband
um
but we I mean you know working in
Creative Industries creative work is not
valued it's always a fight
um it just is what it is and so I had
come from that space I was working a lot
with social justice and Community
Management and Community organization
Grassroots funding Mutual Aid all of
that and I just felt like I was fighting
a losing battle
um I was getting pretty disenfranchised
with everything especially in the
pandemic and then when I discovered web3
it was like oh my God like this is so
different this is so new like we can
build something completely new that
benefits so many more people the change
can be so much bigger what does this
mean for everything like it was just
like an explosion just a catalyst of
like what was what was the first what
was the first thing you what was the
first thing you saw that got you there
do you remember the first thing I saw
yeah I do um it was my husband
um has been in a digital Art Collective
for many years
and uh because he's been an artist a
digital artist forever and so uh he's
showed me uh one of his friends that
I've known for a long time uh was
minting their work and I was like well
what does that mean and he's like well
this is what it means and show me the
whole thing and like I was like well
what happens with royalties what happens
with ownership like it was just
that like that was it I was like oh my
God and then where could that go
immediately I was like well artwork but
then education and real estate and like
what else can happen and
um so I just yeah I threw myself into it
then I became aware of the profile
picture thing
um that movement and I was so fascinated
and I always have been fascinated with
um identity and sense of self and how
people find that within certain places
and
um especially with the internet right so
like within web 2 web and web one how
that has transcended and how digital
identity and Community has formed around
those ideas
I I was like blown away again for the
people that are listening because I know
some people
in this audience have less context to
the term how do you define in layman's
terms digital identity go a little bit
into that because I think people will
enjoy that
so identity in itself uh digital
identity I see is just an extension of
actual physical identity like how you
present yourself to the world how you
communicate who you are what you love
um how you feel what you stand for all
of those things and I think that the
things that we curate around our life
um are extensions and tools of extending
that message right so like I'm wearing
this shirt not it's an intentional
choice I like that [ __ ] but I'm also
sending a message about who I am what I
like all of those things digital
identity is just an extension of that
and we're living increasingly more in
digital spaces
um and so it's an important tool I guess
to to have an impact in the world
to form communities and to to send out
messages and and all of that so no no
different than wearing a Clash
t-shirt in 1979 in London walking around
you were saying to other people hey I'm
into this [ __ ] and literally somebody on
the tube could be like yo yo and you
know next thing you know best friend
married acquaintance wherever it may go
this has been going on forever as we
spend more time digitally same thing
that's it social signaling that's right
in any context that's right um and so I
was seeing that happen with these
profile pages and I was like well [ __ ]
that that's amazing
um but I couldn't I couldn't engage
myself because I didn't feel like
anything represented me I didn't feel
aligned with anything that I saw and
what was this was this like May June
July
of that year
it was like April May April May so
you're looking around and you're like
all right not that you're like all right
Gary's [ __ ] little Doodles [ __ ] that
like you're looking around and you're
like you're looking for something for
you I don't see anything let me make
something that represents what I'm
feeling in my soul that's it I love it I
love it there is nothing that represents
a spectrum of gender there's not nothing
that represents a different side of
culture
um nothing feels like Punk enough sorry
crypto punks but you know yeah no crypto
punks work to your point very basic in
their nature when I think about that
Bella is like you want you know now uh
understanding your background definitely
not Punk enough for you with a dad like
that no and you know what though to to
just segue slightly please played a
really pivotal role in Psych and I
entering the space in a way that they
facilitated so many connections so many
people in the OG Punk Community
um you know gave us our first
opportunities or introduced us to the
next people one Punk um the last Punk
999
um she was one of our devs online and
she's still a lot of contracts for us
like I love that yeah and oh to me that
Community I mean to me it's been the the
only project that I feel like I can go
to sleep and know for a fact that in 40
years when I'm an older man and talking
about this that will definitely be there
is Punks because of history and then why
I want you on the show everything else I
do now is who do I think are the human
Tour de forces that punks will play on
history and what it meant the 5 to 15
that are most meaningful 40 years from
now
whether they're artists like ex copying
people and many others uh amber Victoria
knows people or projects like yours and
mine will completely be based on the
humans ability to navigate the waters
over the next 40 years but to your point
I even just listening to you talk about
it I know what it meant to me just even
like sending to them talking Discord and
like and you know especially the people
that were actually there in 17 and 18
and 19. it's really kind of cool you
know yeah it really felt like they when
I entered the space like I didn't really
have a space for me I didn't feel like
there was anything that I could buy into
where I felt like I belonged and so I
would go to Twitter spaces and I would
join conversations with people that I
thought
um you know would welcome in and they
did and so I would encourage anyone
listening that wants to engage just just
engage like there is a space for you
always but um yeah punks were just back
then I saw them as stewards of the space
um you know proponents of knowledge and
of of all of it I'm not sure how I'm not
sure it's the exact same now like things
change of course not the OTP ones for
sure I just anyway yeah it was great so
I uh I went along that journey and um
injected everything that we love into
dead fellas I wanted people to feel
nostalgic and have an emotional reaction
an emotional connection I wanted all of
the traits that we had to be gender
ambiguous so that during the generative
process you know you could go to the
collection and you could find anything
uh anything had the possibilities to be
you you know it's like no matter who you
were yeah and um and it's worked really
well and how'd your name how'd you name
it
how did I name it yeah it I wish I had a
better answer for this but it literally
all the whole thing came as just a
lightning bolt in my brain and I have
these moments constantly all day every
day and I'm one of those people that um
you know I just constantly buy URLs and
I'm like
it's hot it's hard
to contain ideas sometimes and you know
you have to discern what idea is worth
um when did you when did you so you're
looking around April May I don't see
anything that speaks to me I'm gonna
make something because I'm capable of it
and then during that window a name like
that comes to your mind you go do what I
do because I'm very similar you go to
whatever registry site you go to you see
that it's available maybe it wasn't
available with the S you do it with the
Z right and you just kind of register it
yeah um what happened yeah what happened
was I we did all that
um I had I knew I wanted to do something
and so it took me it was about a week
two weeks and I didn't I when I'm trying
to think of an idea I don't post ideas I
just do my typical thing and I'll like
let them come yep so I was doing things
that I liked to do I was listening to
music I like to listen to I was watching
movies So like
um and the idea of like spooky kind of
Macabre things
um and societal fascination with that
has traveled through time right so
there's like Grimm's Fairy Tales
R.L Stine's Goosebumps books like it
goes through everyone loves it everyone
loves to be a little bit spoofed yeah it
just it is
um
zombies
um since that was brought into pop
culture has just been a thread that is
constant it's just a constant it's a
classic like
you know part of of that whole thing and
so
that winner as soon as I looked onto
that it was like boom done I've got the
idea transparently I did not register
the domain right away because I didn't
have enough money
so I have to um why because it was for
sale it wasn't like 20 bucks it was
already taken it was already taken
ing yeah yep yep you didn't want to show
your hand you didn't want to show your
hand
I want to show my hand so I was like
okay I'm gonna be careful about this
um so I was going to a barbecue with my
friends that day and um I just like took
my friend to the side and I'm like hey
um I just need like 500 bucks this is
gonna sound insane but I can
and try to explain the whole thing and
he was like
um look I have no idea what you're
talking about but yeah she'll do it and
when he was like blown the [ __ ] away
um once it all became what it became
right yeah that's so cool
yeah but how long how long did it take
you to kind of from start you know pen
to paper quote unquote to like when you
had your minting day
um um I'm gonna say it was a couple of
months of solid hard work so again we
were running an agency so right a lot of
you have clients
so many and we were trying to do a lot
of the work ourselves because pandemic
times and housing crisis times and all
of that in Australia we were also in
lockdown with three kids
um so it was just really it was chaotic
it was disgusting chaos like it was
absolutely so that means there was a lot
of 9 P.M to two in the morning
at the time
um so 6 a.m every day I would get up we
would start immediately and then we
would work all the way until about 2 A.M
and then get up again at 6am and that
was like every single day so he would be
working I would be doing treats with him
on Twitter on Facebook like going hard
every single day Betty did you did you
given that you'd been around you know
kind of the creative field getting a
sense for you knowing a little bit about
you through other people's eyes that I
respect
did you have a similar thing that I had
when I was going through it with be
friends did you kind of know it was
going to work
I knew it was going to work before I
even launched it yep and I I still know
exactly where I'm going and it's like it
sounds honestly especially this is
coming from a woman's voice it sounds
conceited and I do I initially when I
would communicate that it it's not
received in the same way
um
like Confidence from a woman is is
received very differently and only by
insecure and unthoughtful absolutely
it doesn't make any less uh annoying to
receive well you know if if to to Value
someone's opinion who would take it
differently from you than me would would
be the mistake that you're making in
that scenario that's exactly it and so I
have to
my experience in this space I'm very
well aware is different and that is
navigating everything from conferences
to
um I've literally everything because I
know this because the founders that I
speak to and I speak to Founders all day
every day are primarily men and so the
the comparison of experience is there
every single day however
um I am built for this and so it doesn't
faze me at all um good
it just is what it is and I feel like
honestly buddy that is that is anybody
who's coming to you with energy that is
completely replicated on them looking at
you differently from because of a gender
situation is just such a dramatically
bigger indicator on them than you like
look look I'll tell you how I say that
as a as a male
it's because I'm 47 and I got really
lucky with a singular life experience
that is now different and we touched on
it earlier yeah my entire life from 14
to 30
I was judged because I was an F student
when I tell you nobody on earth besides
my mother hence why I talked about what
I talked about earlier
all of them thought I had teachers
Mrs stats if you're out there I still
remember this and I don't call out your
name as a negative because you were
actually the sweetest lady she said from
a place of love to me
she said you're going to be a garbage
man
she wasn't trying to be mean to me she
was trying to tell me that you need to
try at this because if you don't your
life will be ruined and it was
unbelievable in America in the 80s and
90s how much your grades were a complete
indicator to how people interacted with
you
yeah it really was the same in the UK
growing up um and then in Australia the
school system was so horrific that it
was not it's not even worth mentioning
um and so anyway nonetheless I know
we're getting on a tandem let me ask you
this because I don't want to run out of
time
a lot of people who are listening are
very aware that like there was the
craziness
that you and I lived through of the
pricing last year obviously there's been
a heavy recorrection I'm sure you have
plenty of people both your partners in
business your friends and acquaintances
everybody around you when somebody says
well what now with nfts like like I
listened very carefully how you
positioned it you know that that's how I
you may know that that's how I think
about be friends too these toys and
Licensing and cartoons and movies and
but when your most cynical friends who
adore you let me say this sentence
carefully cynical friends who adore you
say to you like was it a fad what now
are you okay you know are you okay are
you gonna make it how do you how do you
answer the current energy of this little
moment we're in in this forever game of
the nft technology infrastructure
I I'm gonna be so fine
um what has happened is we are in this
weird situation where we're building
some things so um structurally sound on
like in a in a ball pit in one of those
kids ball pits where it's like it just
shifts all the time the bed of
cryptocurrency is wild we know this
anyone that's like been trading for
years knows this is up and down up and
down you can't conflate the value of
culture that's being born around a brand
and around you know the people that are
engaging with that with the value of
um a turbulent currency
it's a fusser of it for sure because it
was you know in the way utilizing
blockchain technology we're not
um correct focusing our developments on
the movement of the occurrence well it's
it's you know what I tell a lot of
people is you think all nfts are Beanie
Babies you don't realize that it's
stuffed animals it's a forever thing of
course there's Beanie Babies within
stuffed animals
but people people see one project go
from this to that or to your point
ethereum from this to this and they
don't understand that there's a when you
and I think nft we think the whole macro
thing stuffed animals when people that
haven't dug in yet
think about it they think beanie babies
like it's a fad no no there's fads
within it but like 99 of video games
don't end up becoming Super Mario either
yeah so I agree I get it
before we run out of time because we're
kind of quote unquote at time because
I'm getting pushed here in my day-to-day
job
um what did we not touch about comma
I really want a lot of the audience both
the V friends and the Vayner people to
get to know you and your projects and
your creativity and the positive light
you're bringing to the space where can
people find you what did we not touch on
in this short period of time together
that you do want this Mass audience to
know about
um okay so you can find me on Twitter
I'm Betty underscore nft I'm on
Instagram
betty.dfc I'm just dead fellas is the
brand on everything deadfellas.io you
can go to the website and there is like
News Press podcast whatever there's so
much to learn from there you can get
some I've spoken for many hours indeed
yeah I think that just dead fellas in
general
um we are we are proponents of culture
and a social change and we are
disrupters by Nature so
um we will challenge
um structures and systems and have fun
doing it building culture and empowering
people to create content using rip I
love that Betty I continue to root for
you very heavily I was really looking
forward to this if I could ever be a
help to you offline please ping me
thank you so much continued health and
success and all that thank you right
back at you cheers
[Music]